[Música]
imaginaros por un momento
que vivís en un país
dónde
todo está siendo vigilado imaginaros por
un momento
salís a la calle y todos vuestros
movimientos están siendo controlados
imaginaros
por un momento
que vuestra libertad de expresión
no puede ser compartida
ni siquiera por redes sociales
y que todos vuestros datos todos
vuestros derechos humanos están siendo
violados
esta es esto es lo que yo llamo la
dictadura 4.0
esta es una prisión a cielo abierto
imaginaros por un momento que estáis en
vuestra ciudad de origen
imaginaros
que esta es la ciudad de vuestros
abuelos imaginaros
que está saciado de nuestros bisabuelos
de nuestros tatarabuelos imaginaros que
de repente en esta ciudad entre el
ejército entre la policía entre la gente
almería imaginaros que atacan vuestros
mausoleos
imaginaros que logra vais imaginaros que
lo compartís por facebook
imaginaros que lo compartís por vimeo
imaginaros
que vosotras y vosotros que sois hombres
de un país libre de un país laico
por eso sois perseguidos
nos acusan de terrorismo
nos acusan de
o nos pegan nos torturan esto es lo que
yo llamo la dictadura 4.0
[Música]
y él
no
y
en
i
no no no
[Música]
ah
no
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o no
[Música]
dentro de él
no no no
[Música]
o
y
para mí
nunca
sí
no
[Música]
vaya
ah
a
[Música]
bueno
ah
i
y
[Música]
más
bien
[Música]
i
[Aplausos]